buenas tardes a todos la idea de
transmitir una idea en la tarde de hoy
tiene que ver con el compromiso ético es
decir cuanto como vive uno acorde a lo
que sabe y en este caso particular voy a
contar algo que comenzó con una
experiencia personal que muchos jóvenes
han experimentado y que tiene que ver
con el consumo de cannabis también
conocido como planta de marihuana
yo probé la marihuana hace 10 años con
lo cual ya era una persona adulta y
estaba recibido de biólogo y me entró la
curiosidad porque estoy sintiendo lo que
estoy sintiendo cuál es qué es lo que me
está pasando qué moléculas están
interactúan decir la explicación
científica de esto no vamos hablando de
hace unos 10 años atrás con lo cual el
tema no estaba tan en el tapete como hoy
en día así que haciendo utilización de
un inglés muy rudimentario
y pude entrar en contacto con los textos
de los países centrales en cuanto a la
producción de conocimientos científicos
de que era lo que producían las
moléculas que tienen la planta de
marihuana y descubrí algo que es esto
que se llama sistema endocannabinoide
que es el sistema endocannabinoide
es el resultado de 50 años de
investigación que comenzó en israel
desde el momento en que aislaron la
primera molécula responsable del efecto
psicoactivo de la marihuana que es la
molécula conocida como thc ese fue el
inicio del descubrimiento después
descubrieron más moléculas parecidas hoy
en día hay más de 100 cannabinoides y
todos tienen
distintas funciones digamos este es el
primer paso el descubrimiento de los
cannabinoides dijeron si las moléculas
que tiene la planta funcionan en el
cerebro es porque el cerebro produce
algo parecido y se descubrieron los
endocannabinoides después se
descubrieron los receptores es decir las
antenitas de las células donde impactan
las moléculas que tiene la planta y a su
vez las que producen nuestro propio
cerebro
y todo ese conocimiento se integra en lo
que es el sistema endocannabinoide que
en definitiva es un sistema de
comunicación entre células que lo que
hace es llevarlas a la homeostasis oa lo
que se conoce como el equilibrio
básicamente cualquier derivado de la
planta de marihuana lo que va a hacer es
ayudar a conciliar el sueño va a mejorar
la regulación de ese ciclo de sueño
todos los trastornos vinculados al dolor
dolores neuropáticos dolores articulares
y va a aumentar el apetito es bastante
sencillo de ver que si uno duerme come y
no le duele está apuntando a la
recuperación pero esto no es propio del
humano como biólogo me interés en saber
si existían otros animales que tuvieran
este sistema endocannabinoide y descubrí
que las aves también la tienen los
reptiles también la tienen los anfibios
lo tienen pero también lo tienen los
peces
y ahí empieza la duda pues es evidente
que un pez tenga sistema
endocannabinoide no está relacionado con
que pueda consumir la planta no sabe
claramente una planta de marihuana bajo
el agua no se puede hacer pero si existe
este sistema de comunicación que es muy
primitivo y que en todos los organismos
promueve la homeostasis sí es decir un
perro o un gato también lo podemos
llevar al homeostasis en determinado
tipo de enfermedades puntualmente para
qué enfermedades sirven los derivados de
cannabis
enfermedades neurológicas mal de
alzheimer epilepsia refractaria
parkinson temblores constitucionales
dolores neuropáticos síndrome de
tourette también hay otros efectos como
pueden ser
disminución de la presión intraocular
importancia en los procesos autoinmunes
participa en lo que tiene que ver con el
cáncer principalmente tratando efectos
secundarios de la quimioterapia pero
también hay evidencia in vitro de que es
un anticancerígeno entonces es un
conocimiento que uno cuando empieza a
entrar en contacto lo apabulló apabulla
que tenga un potencial terapéutico tan
amplio volviendo a lo mismo de que hace
uno con lo que sabe cuál es el
posicionamiento de tipo que toma frente
a esto lo primero que hice fue empezar a
armar derivados y obviamente para no
ejercer ilegalmente la medicina dárselos
a mis allegados que realmente por ahí la
estaban pasando mal
familiares que porque conocían a gente
que tenía epilepsia refractaria
problemas de sistema nervioso
y problemas de la piel gentes
consolidadas y gente con cáncer y
empezaron a mejorar significativamente
su calidad de vida ahora a la par de eso
había una cuestión con los médicos como
que no acompañan este proceso y uno
indaga en decir si sabes que hace 50
años que existe esto que se viene
desarrollando que los países centrales
han elaborado medicinas en base a esto
que es lo que opera en todo el mundo
para que esta planta siga estando
prohibida o sea no nos olvidemos que en
argentina la pena mínimo por tener
plantas de marihuana es de 4 años y es
una sustancia que tiene comprobado
potencial terapéutico entonces uno de
los factores que influye tiene que ver
con que hay una convención de naciones
unidas o sea la prohibición al nivel del
mundo la impuso naciones unidas en el
año 61
y dijeron textualmente esta sustancia no
tiene potencial terapéutico y es
altamente adictiva hoy en día así que
sabemos que es a esa convención es 30
años antes del sistema endocannabinoide
sabemos que es falsa desde los
científicos o sea a medida que se va
investigando sigue aparecen políticos
que saltan cada vez más propiedades cada
vez que se investiga la planta aparecen
nuevas propiedades y demás
pero no es solamente esta convención del
61 que está diciendo una mentira en el
hecho de que se estableció que la
marihuana era una droga digamos entonces
al ubicarla en ese lugar se limitó el
acceso a la investigación científica y
por otro lado en el caso de argentina en
base a esa ley se hizo la 23737 una ley
que éste
penaliza a los médicos si receta en una
sustancia que naciones unidas dice que
no tiene potencial terapéutico y es
adictivo ese hay una doble prohibición
en algo que supuestamente ni siquiera
tiene esos efectos
ahora también opera el hecho de que
prácticamente ningún médico esté en
contacto con el sistema endocannabinoide
es decir cuando fueron a estudiar
medicina no estaban en sus contenidos
teóricos el sistema endocannabinoide
entonces que le mostraban de la
marihuana que era una droga nada más así
toxicología si fumas mucho puede pasar
esto te puede que en la guardia una
persona así guasa pero no hay una forma
por ambas con cien ciudad de de abordar
este tema así en el caso de la pampa se
va dando un fenómeno particular que es
qué
cada vez más gente entra en contacto con
los derivados de la planta porque hay
mucha gente que está cultivando y demás
y empiezan a sentir estos beneficios
terapéuticos que tienen el tema es cómo
garantizar el suministro ante una
sustancia que es ilegal y hay un
problema gravísimo porque porque el
estado en un rol tibio viene avanzando
con la legalización viene avanzando con
el reconocimiento del uso medicinal de
la planta pero como no garantiza los
mecanismos de acceso todavía todo esto
está librado al narcotráfico serio es
decir la gente que se está encargando de
proveer de aceite o de derivados de
plantas producirlas es gente que está en
la ilegalidad total
y eso hace que mucha gente que tiene una
necesidad sanitaria se contacte por ahí
con personas que no son idóneas porque
hay que aclarar algo se habla de aceite
de cannabis pero no existe el aceite de
cannabis el aceite de cannabis depende
de la variedad y hay más variedades de
cannabis que razas de perro por lo tanto
ahí tenés una variable importante
depende de la concentración depende de
cómo hayas cultivado la planta depende
como dosifique es depende de la edad del
sexo de la persona pero también depende
la patología si no existe un aceite el
aceite es un un preparado prácticamente
artesanal digamos es decir está hecho en
base a un montón de variables que hay
que conocer entonces también se podría
investigar la planta pero también hay
limitantes para poder hacer
investigación con esto no entonces en
definitiva el objetivo de esta charla
informarlos a ustedes decirles que esto
existe que es verdad y de alguna manera
ver qué es lo que van a hacer ahora
ustedes con este conocimiento cómo se
van a parar desde el compromiso ético
que corresponde con esto vamos a ayudar
a la gente que está enferma los médicos
van a ayudar o van a seguir diciendo no
no hay mucha evidencia o sea no leí nada
de los últimos 50 años pero yo no hay
evidencia no no
vos no tenés la evidencia pero yo esto
es algo que debe modificarse es un
cambio cultural es lento y demás así que
muchísimas gracias y espero que les haya
servido
[Aplausos]